during the pandemic people from all
walks of life have stepped forward as
everyday superheroes from frontline
workers to teachers
parents keeping their families fed we
recently told you about angelina ritto
who was inspired by a tv superhero
linda carter's wonder woman rito started
a business making mass
based on the famous character and carter
herself
actually bought one we wanted to give
this entrepreneur a chance
to tell her story the 70s tv series
wonder woman
and linda carter the actress who played
the iconic role
have been inspiring young women for
decades including
angelina ritto she's obviously the most
beautiful woman in the universe
but she empowered us little girls we can
do and be anything we want
when the pandemic hit ritto channeled
wonder woman's
strong can-do attitude into an online
mask making business
when did you decide that you wanted to
start making wonder woman masks
oh i started those right away rito's
mask caught the eye of her hero
linda carter when you found out that
linda carter
placed an order for one of your masks
what went through your mind oh my gosh i
fell off the couch i was so shocked and
so stunned my
uh my heart was just racing carter's
order included a heartfelt note from
riddle
i had to take a moment to thank you for
influencing my life
on and off screen you are the woman who
inspired me
in addition to raising two sons and two
amazing wonder woman
a marine and a health professional rito
just earned her bachelor's degree as an
ultrasound sonographer
i went back to school at the age of
48. rito also admitted to carter
i was super nervous sewing your mask i
made one too large
decided to send it to you as well when
carter tweeted rido's note
and a photo of her wonder woman mask
sales exploded
if you could talk to linda
what would you say oh gosh thank you
this
is one of the greatest moments of my
life
i'm so honored that's when we decided it
was time to make one of riddo's greatest
moments
a little more wonderful i have a
surprise for you and someone wants to
say hello
no hello
angelica oh my wonder woman
oh my god thank you so
much you're welcome how beautiful she is
oh my god i'm thrilled to be with you
today
i've been listening to you tell your
story what struck me
about your letter is your honesty
is your straightforwardness is your
uh self-deprecation you say oh i
i was so nervous i made the first one
too big
so i just threw that one in too it was
so refreshing and so honest this is the
greatest moment of my life
this is every dream come true thank you
so much
hello there you little darling you've
got me begging you for mercy
and while riddle continues producing
masks carter
the singer is producing new music
hopefully in the next
three weeks a
new single and what really
single yes it's called human and divine
for angelina ritto being able to talk
with one of her favorite humans
was truly divine to speak to my iconic
hero
it it's it's like
a dream right now it's i'm so
shocked and amazed i can't even speak we
were so happy to make that moment happen
for angelina and
you know it's remarkable these actors
who play superheroes in the films on
television
in the case of wonder woman linda carter
her strength through humility her
intelligence that comes through and when
you're a little kid
you will you gravitate to that and it
does set a tone for how you conduct
yourself
in life i just believe that because i
was a huge fan of i mean i was the same
as angelina
i heard that yeah it was a really
producer on this piece said
you may have been more excited than
angelina carter
i want to say who who do we need to get
on the zoom call or show
next for you who would you who's your
mark hamill okay
oh man mark hamill john tower you heard
it
you got to work on this for your
birthday next year okay
it might take that long right